thank you for being there like a mom
and supporting me through some of the
toughest times you will be missed
this surprise party in 2019 was the last
birthday
jonathan farrington spent with his
beloved mother dawn
before she embarked on a new life
my mom was to put us simply my best
friend
dawn lived apart from her husband frank
galenchen for a decade
while she worked at a long-term care
home in oshawa ontario
he built their retirement home in the
beautiful seaside village of
port-au-prince nova scotia
when she retired they were finally
together living their dream
when she got down there you know as hard
as it was for all of us
it was the best moment of her life i'm
sure
but that moment didn't last less than a
year later
tragedy struck good evening thank you
for joining us on what has been an
incredibly difficult and tragic day in
nova scotia and in the maritimes
on the night of april 18th frank and don
galentin
were murdered their future and their
dream home
torched a nightmare you know
it's uh again
i i haven't come to terms with it i can
honestly say
today's probably been the first day that
it's actually hit me
the loss of his mother hit hard on this
particular day which
would have been her 63rd birthday
jonathan
his fiancee abigail thompson and his
adopted sister tristina arnold spent it
sharing memories and regrets you just
wish you talked more and texts more and
visited more a few mementos
notes of condolence from canadians and
the couple's ashes are all the family
has left
everything else was incinerated in the
house fire in puerto pic
i'm a firm believer that she's with us
now and
getting more positive energy to do it
and you know
to tell the story of her life and
my dad's life
so many questions remain unanswered
about how a single gunman
could roam freely to burn to kill so
many
for so long 22 people
were massacred in 13 hours
they got the killer right here they got
him on lockdown they're going for him
right now
they got the killer right here the
rampage finally ended when mounties ran
into the murderer at this gas station by
chance and killed him
criticism of the rcmp response came
almost immediately
one of the most persistent questions is
why they didn't do more to warn the
public
it's very vague what's going on down
there but there is
for sure multiple patients down there
[Applause]
rcmp arrived in puerto pick at 10 26
on the night of april 18th but the only
alert that night
was a vague tweet about a firearms
complaint
what's more the rcmp didn't tell nova
scotians who their suspect was
until the next morning but radio
communications show they had that
information
in the early hours of their
investigation permission here is the
container
locating the rest are suspected
our suspect is clear warming in fact
a wounded witness had told mounties
almost immediately
when they first arrived on scene he had
been shot by a man named
gabe and that the suspect was driving
what looked like
a police car
[Music]
saying they don't know they didn't know
till 6am
who the shooter was meanwhile you know
there's a victim that told them
you know at 10 30 in the evening who the
who the
suspect was in the days that followed
the shootings rcmp
offered contradictory information or
none at all
on april 20th this was the response to
questions about
why the province's emergency alert
system wasn't used
it's a good question and i don't have an
answer for you at this moment
then they claimed twitter was a more
effective way of alerting people that
there was a mass
murderer on the loose we had relied on
on twitter as my colleague said because
of its
the instantaneous manner that we can
communicate say their
their tweet alone you know where's their
accountability for that
who's got what 62 year olds are on
twitter
on april 22nd here's how police
addressed questions about
why the public wasn't notified earlier
that the killer was
impersonating a police officer the
information about the vehicle
the clothing took some time to
learn from the one witness
then a couple days later a completely
different answer
fairly early into our involvement we
learned of a possible suspect
and learned the individual lived in a
home within that same community in porto
peak
there is perhaps no better example of
the rcmp's fractured response and lack
of accountability than what happened at
this fire hall on the morning of april
19th
i heard shots and then the wife started
screaming
pat mccabe and his wife lived next door
to the fire hall which was designated as
a refuge for people fleeing portapik
they saw an unmarked rcmp vehicle arrive
and then chaos two people got out one on
each side of the car left the doors open
and they started shooting from the road
the gunfire sent an emergency management
office employee
scrambling for cover by sheer luck
bullets missed him
and missed an rcmp car stationed in the
parking lot
with a mountie sitting inside either of
them
or others in the area could have easily
been killed
what i can do is i can provide you with
some general comments
for months police declined to answer
questions about what happened at the
fire hall
pending an investigation when the report
was finally released in february it made
clear that police were
totally unprepared to deal with a
suspect who was dressed
like them their radios weren't working
and rather than wait for more
information
officers started yelling at the man they
saw in the parking lot
and then opened fire the report found
the communication issues that morning
were due to the heavy volume of radio
traffic
it also found the officers had
reasonable grounds to think they saw the
gunman in the parking lot
and fired to stop him no charges were
laid
and the rcmp will only say they're
looking into the radio problem
[Music]
it's been more than 10 months since the
rcmp has answered questions about the
shootings
in december they did charge gabriel
wartman's common-law partner lisa
banfield
her brother james banfield and
brother-in-law brian brewster
with illegally transferring ammunition
to the killer
but rcmp claimed they didn't know what
wartman was going to do
on the weekend of the shootings jonathan
farrington and his fiancee say police
continue to keep them in the dark just
literally almost everything regarding
this case i've
i've got from social media from the
get-go i don't think they've actually
ever told us information that we haven't
already heard
it took 11 months for the nova scotia
government to finally introduce
legislation to make it illegal for
people to own police equipment like
cars and uniforms so far that
is the only thing the province has done
but there was a response
from the federal government last week 22
canadians were killed in the deadliest
rampage
in our country's history only days after
the nova scotia massacre prime minister
justin trudeau used nova scotia's
tragedy
to announce a long-promised piece of gun
control legislation
today we are closing the market for
military-grade
assault weapons in canada
it seemed like a pledge finally
fulfilled to victims families and
survivors of
another horrific mass shooting this
is i'm told the worst shooting disaster
in canadian history
those who escaped the infamous
polytechnic massacre have been pushing
for stronger gun laws
ever since a shooter murdered 14 women
at the montreal school in 1989. and
there is a chilling connection
to nova scotia one of the things that we
learned after the nova scotia shooting
was that
the gunman in that case had a ruger mini
14 that he used
the same weapon that was used in
polytechnic 30 years ago 31 years ago
now
how do you feel knowing that
you cannot imagine how mad i am
natalie provo was shot four times at
polytechnic
but survived she understands better than
most the heavy toll of gun violence
i remember seeing the eyes of one of my
friends
closing and understanding that it was
really really
dangerous that that it was the end for
her i
have very very profound wounds
that i was able to overcome
but never totally they are
in me for my whole life
the liberals 2019 election platform also
included a pledge to buy back
all military-style assault rifles but
when they
introduced bill c21 the buyback was
voluntary
and i think that's a betrayal
polytechnic survivors like heidi rathgen
were outraged
as long as these weapons are still out
there accessible
they can be used by their owners they
can be stolen and used
the prime minister has made a habit of
attending memorials for the victims of
the polytechnic massacre
but now survivors say he's no longer
welcome
the families that i've spoken with over
the last year
of the victims in nova scotia the people
who witnessed it
a lot of them are expressing frustration
with police and with politicians
over what they say is a lack of
accountability and a lack of answers
what do you think when you hear that
people in nova scotia
have a right to be angry to be
frustrated of what happened
of our law of our regulation i really
can understand them
and that lack of accountability seems to
permeate
every level of government in february
nova scotia's outgoing premier stephen
mcneil bid farewell with a familiar
talking point
the inquiry i'm sure is going to bring
us
you know recommendations things that
will have to change
that inquiry is only happening because
enraged nova scotians demanded it
they'll have to wait until at least 2022
for answers
because they aren't getting them from
the new premier there's so many things
we can do
i believe and there is an independent
inquiry that will go over
everything from top to bottom that
involves different levels of government
[Music]
that's not good enough for those left to
pick up the pieces like jonathan
farrington
he knows nothing will bring back his
mother and father but
after a year of waiting for answers his
faith in the entire system
is gone my trust in the inquiry and my
trust in the rcmp as a whole there's
there's none he's part of a proposed
class-action lawsuit against the
mounties and the government of nova
scotia
after the murder of jonathan's parents
first responders in ontario paid tribute
in a memorial procession
a show of solidarity that he says gives
him more comfort
than anything the rcmp have done it's
just
they seem untouchable it's just you know
they don't have to provide anything to
us so you sum it up as
lives are lost shooter's gone to me it
just feels like everything's just being
swept under the carpet and
hey you know what we expect the families
to move on with life fingers crossed
kind of thing